la mer est calme mais petros creepin'
thirith est agitée depuis que près de 10
mille demandeurs d'asile ont été
relocalisés le long des côtes qu'ils
naviguent tous les jours j'ai très peur
quand je passe près du camp vous ne
pouvez pas avoir dix ou douze mille
personnes dans un si petit espace dit il
c'est un gros problème
j'ai peur qu'ils nous donnent le
coronavirus ils ne sont pas propres
même au centre ville le pêcheur n'est
plus à l'aise
eq à l'acte aujourd hui joyau l'automne
yoyo la vie a tellement changé sur l'île
et ces gens là se plaignent de tout dix
commerçants à propos des exilés ils
veulent toujours plus mais qui dit qu'on
doit leur donner tout ça ils veulent
aller ailleurs mais où peuvent-ils aller
personnes en europe n'ont vu l' incendie
du camp de moria a ramené en avant-plan
l'échec de la politique migratoire de
l'union européenne une politique dans la
grèce seul fait les frais dit on au
détour des petites rues de mytilène
dimitris professeur à la retraite croit
que la présence des demandeurs d'asile
sur son hymne et contre nature pour
coiffer un viol chaque être vivant a
besoin de son espace vital propres
dit-il il vous ne verrez jamais un ours
dans le désert pas plus que vous ne
verrez un chameau près de l'océan
arctique résume-t-il
quand même et à millas sont pas roumains
locarno si ces sentiments sont exprimés
par une majorité de la population de
l'île de lesbos il reste encore des
habitants pour qui c'est la solidarité
qui doit primer mosaïque est un oasis de
solidarité envers les étrangers de
lesbos ici on s'efforce de tisser des
liens avec la population locale par
l'entremise d'ateliers de couture et
d'expression artistique
les grecs ont plus à apprendre des
migrants qui ne le croit dit lula une
intervenante ici avec cnt sont si forts
et puissants ils sont heureux au fond
j'ai plus pitié pour nous que pour eux
ils sont optimistes malgré tout ce
qu'ils ont vécu
ils ont une énergie positive sans jamais
se plaindre
nv
complet c'est un point de vue qui reste
minoritaire angaelos musa là se réclame
d'une majorité qui n'en peut plus
propriétaires de terres et bâtiments à
quelques pas du nouveau camp de karaté
paix et dit vivre un enfer depuis 2015
au fil des marées des arrivées par
bateau il a vu sa propriété tantôt
piller soulier incendié sa colère des
premiers jours a été remplacé par un
sentiment de vide dit il sont traités de
fascistes pour ses positions
il n'en a plus que faire woods ou un
miroir on ne doit à personne de nourrir
qu'il se soit sur ces deux-là net alors
que ceux qui les ont amenés ici les mène
à leur destination dit il et leur
destination c'est le reste de l'union
européenne
une robe hypocrite qui a oublié le sens
de l'union croit-il qui critiquent de
loin sans assumer sa part de
responsabilité
ici marie-eve bédard radio-canada lesbos